[Music]
i was curious about something uh i know
for a fact that you shot an ad for the
super bowl i did and i was excited for
you and i watched the whole super bowl
and i never saw your ad and i got cut
for some reason i don't know what
happened i mean i i it was all ready to
go it's for a great product and they
never showed it so if you'd like if i
can can i show it here now yeah i mean
it's completely uh crazy but sure all
right do they have it in the booth ready
to go i think they probably do all right
that's right we rehearsed this
all right
well i want to see let's all see andy's
rejected super bowl ad all right
let's roll my super bowl ad
is using the bathroom at your workplace
an embarrassing nightmare
are you afraid that your co-workers will
know that it's you in that stall because
they recognize your shoes
hey andy
i know it's you
we'll never be embarrassed again with
the all-new shoe covers
just simply place the shoe covers over
your shoes and no one will ever know
that it's you in there
shoe covers come in a wide variety of
styles and designs
and with shoe covers you can hide in the
bathroom all day without your boss ever
catching on
so do your business at your business
with confidence
order shoe covers today
[Applause]
how did i not know you had a super bowl
ad if i'm in it
i don't
know that was that was an incredible
lookalike yeah exactly all right
that guy must make a lot of money
playing conan at parties
mostly children's parties